welcome to this video lengths of a
command from Switzerland and a play
reversed Grand Prix which is an
interesting opening it's better than the
he it's better than the normal Grand
Prix actually with an extra temple ok
Knight f3 this is surround with
interesting move
yeah I'm Bishop before is probably going
to play 95 efore probably night H form
yeah okay explain far too much time here
let's do that 95 I'm globish up c5 it
shouldn't be at the end of the world and
maybe he's not even playing it at least
took him a couple of seconds okay so
thank you Wow
I'm really shocked here why is this what
I told what um this is quite strange my
not a piece up here oh I've got Bishop
before check or is there some way that
he gets both pieces I mean it's a bit
weird everything is hanging and stuff
but gave the check first down this
Bishop it doesn't have many squares but
if I go if I just retreat this annoyed
you can say here on c5 c6 getting
squares here
yeah this should be fine I'm the piece
up I mean I just need to make sure that
I'm not walking into some some made or
anything at the system is actually
helping me giving another temple quite
resigned yeah he just he just blundered
to blunder distance was wasn't working
night xt5 was one of the most shocking
news that in recent times Wow when I
take c-5m the the normal movie is just
d3y our castles I just expected this and
then maybe maybe this I know just just
the normal just normal move and yeah and
i take c 5 wasn't it wasn't working at
all the point is is always the checking
and i'm a piece up so very quick win
thanks for watching